[Música]
Hola les damos la bienvenida a enlace
Centroamérica desde Costa Rica hoy
hablaremos sobre la recuperación del
turismo post pandemia Costa Rica es uno
de los destinos más apetecidos y
populares a nivel mundial gracias a su
reputación como un país que cuida su
naturaleza con una matriz energética
100% renovable y sin fuerzas armadas
desde hace más de 70 años se ha
posicionado principalmente entre
estadounidenses y europeos que buscan
Vivir la experiencia Pura vida les
contaremos sobre la importancia que
tiene la industria para la economía
nacional las claves de su éxito el
impacto de la pandemia sobre el sector Y
cómo planea recuperarse plenamente en
el país de 51 mil kilómetros cuadrados y
con una población de 5 millones de
habitantes tiene playas en el Pacífico y
el Caribe Islas volcanes Ríos montañas
varios tipos de bosque y selva aquí se
encuentra cerca del 5% de la
biodiversidad del planeta protegida en
áreas de conservación que abarcan el 25%
del territorio ofrece además distintos
tipos de experiencia naturaleza
bienestar cultura y Aventura
se siente que somos parte de la
naturaleza porque todo está protegido y
se siente como si pudieras entrar en su
mundo lo cual es realmente agradable la
gente es hospitalaria ha sido
increíblemente amable
Me encanta como puedes ir a un volcán ir
a la playa hay una gran variedad y
belleza
el país también es una opción atractiva
para turistas de larga estancia o
nómadas digitales gracias a su
estabilidad y seguridad pero también a
las leyes que crean incentivos para
extranjeros que desean vivir aquí es un
lugar muy acogedor llevo tres años
tomando clases de español trabajar en mi
español para conectarme con las personas
más locales ha sido muy importante para
mí Para no sentirme que soy siempre una
turista sino que podría ser mi hogar
algún día el turismo uno de los
principales motores de la economía
costarricense aporta entre el 6% y 8%
del producto interno bruto y genera unos
450.000 empleos directos e indirectos lo
que representa el 18% del total de la
fuerza de trabajo por eso la pandemia y
el cierre de fronteras a nivel mundial
significaron un fuerte desplome inédito
para el país las fronteras aéreas
costarricenses permanecieron cerradas
entre marzo y agosto de 2020 según la
cámara de comercio en la llamada
temporada 0 es decir sin visitantes del
exterior se vieron obligadas a cerrar
unas tres mil quinientas empresas
formales y el mayor golpe se sintió en
el sector turístico donde el 87% son
micro pequeñas y medianas empresas
muchas de ellas resistieron
reinventándose
empanadas y hacíamos
de lo que se pudiera para que la gente
fuera a repartir y ahí lleva San José a
todo lado y la gente los apoyó demasiado
Costa Rica fue de los primeros países de
la región en reabrir sus fronteras
aéreas y ha venido recuperándose poco a
poco cerró el 2022 con más de dos
millones de turistas que llegaron al
país pero todavía el ingreso percibido
no alcanza los niveles pre pandemia Hay
hoteles full eh a nosotros acá nos hay
un muy muy bien en 2023 la meta es que
lleguen a Costa Rica unos tres millones
de turistas es decir alcanzar los
niveles de visitación de 2019 el año
antes de la emergencia sanitaria para
ello ha sido clave propiciar el regreso
de las líneas aéreas parte del plan para
la recuperación plena del sector es
también el acceso a financiamiento
accesible para empresas pequeñas y
medianas y empujar el crecimiento del
sector turístico en las zonas costeras
menos desarrolladas otra de las tácticas
es la adaptación a nuevos tipos de
visitantes antes era predominante la
visita de familias pero ahora también
hay un importante número de gente joven
que viaja sola en pareja o en grupos por
lo que las empresas han modificado sus
productos y servicios para esa nueva
corriente de compradores de la gran
lección que tiene todo el mundo es que
tenemos que vivir el hoy tenemos que
vivir el presente y disfrutar ese
presente y eso Tiene un gran efecto
sobre el turismo ya la acumulación de
riqueza ahorros ya no va a ser tanto
viendo un futuro muy lejano es si tengo
si tengo esto voy a disfrutarlo un reto
pendiente es evitar que el destino se
vuelva inalcanzable debido a sus costos
no solo para el turista internacional
sino también para el nacional que a
veces se queja por no poder disfrutar de
algunos sitios en que prevalecen ofertas
de lujo y en lo personal el apoyo al
comercio local más de todo después de la
pandemia el poder ir a lugares
pequeñitos y poder aprovechar tours
conocer es algo muy bonito que uno
también le puede contribuir a la
comunidad tenemos que ser conscientes
que en nuestro país tiene cosas hermosas
que tenemos que compartir pero que
tampoco tampoco podemos hacerlas
inaccesibles
no solo la gente que viene afuera Si no
sobre toda la gente que vivimos acá otro
desafío para el país es balancear el
desarrollo turístico evitando los
efectos negativos de la gentrificación
es decir que la llegada y el
asentamiento de población extranjera no
desplace O perjudique a la población
autóctona hasta aquí con este enlace
Centroamérica sobre Costa Rica Gracias
por habernos acompañado para ver
nuestros programas síganos por France 24
y France 24.com